big hit check me out on bootleg cev
podcast whoa whoa hey this interview is
brought to you by our good Folks at
Imperial extractions ladies and
gentlemen now check this out if you want
a free 2 G pre-roll delivered right to
your door they got you go get a free 2 G
thca Diamond infused pre-roll with any
order right now we're talking about 1
and half grams of top shell flour and a
half a gram of pure thca diamonds
Imperial
extraction. code bootleg and you're
going to get this for free delivered
right to your door let's get to the
interview yo bootle Kev podcast special
guest here he just dropped his this is
his debut album yes
sir the truth is in my eyes truth is in
my eyes I'd like to point out this is
very highly anticipated thank you for
bringing me a physical copy for sure man
guaranteed you you the [__] man people
aren't doing these no more so and this
is legit come on
man some some people do a CD but it's
like see you don't got the book see this
is the full you got the whole this is
vintage bro yeah man this is fire um
first of all before we like get into the
specifics of the album what I noticed
that you're doing which I think is
actually smart these days is you can't
go to Spotify for this album no man you
got to only cop this on big hit n.com
you feel me yeah so what was cuz
obviously for people who don't know like
if you get a million streams it's like
37 $0000 which is pretty wild for being
honest um but if people like what what
what was the inspiration for you to you
know make people buy the album like
actually spend money on the
album I mean that's you know that's the
Mastermind here you know what I'm saying
here boy so we just basically just said
[__] it just ball hogging just doing us
uh we lose a draw and uh like it or love
it yeah you know what I'm saying type
situation we just create making good
music and uh and pushing Full Speed
Ahead with it you know what I'm saying
the album's been out um a few days what
has been the response and how has how
has this business model worked out so
far oh it's it's A1 man it's it's all
booming it's they fans is tapping in
they they coping the magazines they
coping the shirts Tru shirts going free
shirts yep well I'm glad well I'm glad
that you guys are doing it this way
because like I feel like something has
to give for like kind of like currently
how artists are compensated for their
art you know what I'm saying yeah I feel
it my [__] like doing [__] for free
it's really what it is ain't nobody in
in no other game is doing [__] for free
you can't go to the to the man and and
get a brick [__] on ass my [__] tell
[__] I'm I got you later n is doing
that [__] man and dudes is really like
devaluing you know the game like it's
just it's really just just [__] the
game up for you um talk about because
you and ever since you got out this this
last go round I feel like you and your
son have just been in your bag like I
mean it's been crazy to watch just kind
of like the buzz that You' generated
just immediately the quality of records
that you were putting out on his [__] I
mean um the visuals have been there I
know you guys celebrated you guys shot
one one of your videos uh shot my club
in Arizona he was out there with all my
bottle girls SC turned up I loved it for
sure AZ shout out AZ my [__] um but
this album man like um you know it is it
is a highly anticipated album so you
know for you like uh kind of give me
like the rundown of just how you feel
about this man finally getting it off
your chest it's got to feel good with so
many roadblocks that have come up in
your life and you know we we could have
got this album a decade ago yeah you
know yeah yep yeah for sure but you know
it's like like a process man a building
process and the learning process and
just now just got to capitalize and you
know and uh push Full Speed Ahead man
and uh you know make it make sense you
know for I'm I'm like just all I know
right now that's all I'm doing you're
like a full-time rapper for real yeah I
ain't out there grinding like one foot
in one foot out like my [__] Benny say
that's real [__] you know what I'm
saying that's what I was doing last time
too and the [__] wasn't working I feel
like anybody who does the one put out
one footing thing is it's there's like
an expiration date on that we see it
every almost every time moment at any
given moment you might get pulled over
with a gun you might there's so many
like little things that could go wrong
every day K or you might kill a [__]
anything you know what I'm saying it's
like yeah it's like you might as well
Focus so like for you like um talk to me
about like uh is there going to be any
sort of opportunity for the generic fan
to just stream this one day or is it
just like hey this is only going to be
something you could buy yeah it's like a
piece of art yeah yeah it's it's some
art right now I'm not really sure how
they doing it maybe later they feel like
they know might put streaming out or
whatever but right now we ball hogging
and we on to the next it's like this is
done so I know we got to push this but
we like we still creating music man we
just every day oh the work ethic over
there at hit spot is it's just it's just
non-stop I'm sure you probably already
got another album ready I got 10 albums
that's what I'm saying like 10 albums
ready man so I feel like when he locks
in it's just over like look at all the n
i mean the nas thing I don't even know
how many Nas albums we've gotten so far
it's been crazy six on record six of
them another Grammy
nomination what's it like uh meeting and
hanging with Nas oh man he he a king man
a soldier man shout out Nas my [__] you
know uh give my utmost respect man my
highest regards he like he He Man Nas
like he he he just like he n my [__]
you can't like you meet another
[__] he's not that dude you know
what I'm saying like I didn't know n you
know what I'm saying but but however I
seen Naza and however he portrayed
himself that's how blood was when I met
him you know what I'm saying it wasn't
no different from the movie [__] to
[__] uh B that belly [__] you feel me
that was the realest [__] to me myig on
God yeah yeah my [__] you know him and
X was off that [__] but uh but so he he
didn't disappoint no he a real one were
you able to like kind of chop it up with
him about like just kind of like cuz I
feel like what what your son has done
with nas is is unprecedented lowkey you
know what I mean like I feel like
uh I I mean Nas just do this [__] man
cuz it's in his heart it's in his soul
that's a part of him my [__] like a
athlete he's like bouncing the ball
[__] is nothing for real so yeah and
like that Grammy is like a big deal the
Grammy that they won that's like a
that's got that's like you know
obviously shout out to H it's not like
it's his only Grammy but like that
Grammy to me I feel like was like it had
to have meant so much cuz it was with
Nas and it was like years after his
initial run you know what I'm saying
yeah so man they man took him a long
time to break him off man they should
have been gave Nas's flowers for sure
man you know what I'm saying talk to me
man just like about you uh what what
first of all uh how long have you been
rapping and give me kind of like some of
your background like like what part of
Cali are you from you know what I'm
saying like how long have you been
making music cuz you're you're like the
OG you know what I'm saying I'm sure you
you had a lot of the you know
inspiration as to why he ended up taking
his career path to where it was yeah I
mean I grew up [__] with the old
school you know what I'm saying the the
uh the krs1 the biz Marky the [__]
you know back to Uncle Jam's Army type
[__] but um but yeah I'm from Pasadena
PDL shout out to pasaden y w city of
roses and um yeah I just been I've been
spitting all my life for real just
Clowning with it though I never you know
what I'm saying it was just a part of me
like I say it was just something that
you just lived and breathe it was like
yeah I always did it and clowned with it
and you know [__] always say oh that's
tight but I never took it serious you
know what I'm saying what was the
closest you had taken it to like
obviously prior to the hs87 wave when
when you were on grinding all my life
and all that but was there like a a
earlier era where you were close to kind
of like putting out music or or being
like more of a serious artist where you
were kind of like considering n that was
the only time I really you know what I'm
saying was uh Ser cuz I was fres shot I
didn't have a chance been in jail [__]
before that it was just like a hobby
yeah I just spitting you know was young
little you know what I'm saying just
kicking it clowning with with friends
but um other than that just remixing
[__] right know he was remixing I was
remixing way back then just jumping on
Beats yeah jumping on Beach and redoing
the same [__] like Bobby Jimmy did that
roaches look at all these roaches that
[__] yeah just Clowning [__] like that
but uh yeah Pasadena is a city that uh
doesn't get a lot of recognition or love
when we think about La n we underrated
my [__] and I love Pasadena it's one of
my favorite cities to go to to get food
and transs my [__] oh God what do you
mean by that I mean [__] we set the tone
my [__] on a lot of [__] on [__] that's
that said my [__] like NOP it all that
[__] you know what I'm saying I was
going to say like what do you what do
you think it is about padena that like
there's a few areas of La that kind of
are underappreciated if you will yeah I
think Pasadena is one of them like Pasad
is absolutely you know what I'm saying
this is uh yeah we for sure we
underrated but um and like people don't
understand it also gets slept on and we
just you know what I'm saying we had to
turn up and we just never turned down
you know what I'm saying to get our
respect and and I think most people go
to Pasadena and they go to either the
rosebowl or they go and they get food
cuz they got that street that's got all
the restaurants but it it does get
active over there they was yeah they was
looking at us like you know I don't know
what Hollywood or some [__] but I mean
and it's a nice area you get tricked if
you come over there for sure you know
what I'm saying thinking you you safe in
a good little area and start going up
but yeah that was the that was the main
thing probably you get tricked by just
the surroundings yeah but the
individuals in their
cities vicious I feel like anywhere in
La you get tricked they got hoods
everywhere they got I didn't realize
some some spots you know you feel the
presence of of danger you know what I'm
saying like you don't really feel that
in Pasadena know what I'm saying even
now right now feel [__] feel like I'm in
[__] Westco or something I was going
say when you got out you had to probably
be like damn this [__] changed Big Time
Y A lot of people in the hood that's not
even from the hood basically all the
homies they a lot of people moved out
cuz the [__] inflation can't afford
itra it's crazy you know what I'm saying
I I looking at houses bro I was looking
at houses over there it's crazy yeah you
got to move like it's yep yeah we going
we going to change that we going to get
to these millions and these billions I'm
a b the whole Hood I love it man um you
have a bunch of dope features on this
project uh shout out to Jay Worley shout
out to Baby Stone gorillas I saw
Alchemist is on here uh obviously your
son's on here what since you've been out
you've worked with so many artists who
has been like the funnest studio
session where you guys just had a great
time
recording
[__]
man all of them been going up you know
all of them go up my [__] for
real man all of them man Mazy [__] I
guess with Don Kennedy with J every last
one of them man T Fly I be probably t
fly man he's he be clowning like a
mother T Fly is like a very underrated
guy too yeah [__] he's hilarious but
yeah know he's so fire yeah um for you
man talk to me about like you know you
grown up we mentioned Caris one we
mentioned a lot of that but like you
know the music game has changed so much
like hip-hop has kind of evolved for
like a generation like my son who's 18
he's listening to [__] I would never
even entertain listening to you know
what I mean but I feel like that's what
people love you cuz you're bringing like
an energy I feel like is just not a part
of the game no more you know what I'm
saying do you feel that like do you feel
that pressure like I feel like that's
why people resonate with you because
you're making like the [__] that we need
you know what I'm saying like I don't
think people even wanted to even like or
or even knew that we needed I'm not
here s I'm just doing me man like hoping
I don't even really can't say I hope
they accept it you know what I'm saying
I mean I'm just doing me regardless like
I'm not trying to please nobody um fit
in you know I'm saying I'm trying to
basically just dig my own pave my own
way yeah you know what I'm saying to add
on to the to the Legacy you know what
I'm saying with h boy built man and
catch
up when uh you linked with Snoop what
was that like
Snoop that's like that's un man you know
what I'm saying is he always got
something positive to say you know what
I'm saying and that's that's that's love
you know what I'm saying coming from he
he he know the struggle I'm saying he
done been there he know the struggle my
[__] so he he can relate you know what
I'm saying and I when I do look at Snoop
and you know I'm saying eye to eye my
[__] I can look at [__] in the eye
like damn this the homie yeah you know
what I'm saying he ain't no fake ass
[__] just on some rapper [__] I'm sure
you've been dealing with that a lot too
just dealing with kind of like this
industry is so fake like you you'll meet
somebody they'll tell you one thing yeah
it's just it's a very shallow industry
trip though I mean I take everybody for
face v i don't you know what I'm saying
right you don't take I'm authentic so I
I you know I carry everybody like they
authentic too until they show me
different you know what I'm saying real
talk I don't underestimate nobody none
of that [__] I
know I got like I said I got little
white PS [__] for 150 lb soaking wet
like [__] Killers you know what I'm
saying you can't judge nobody body a
book for real you say white Partners
hell yeah okay for sure shout out to the
white guys hell yeah for sure like essay
[__] Crips Bloods GDs V I'm universal
you know what I'm saying can't put me in
the Box hey what up y'all I'm excited
because I'm going to be flying to Tampa
to DJ the odd Sox holiday party next
week and of course as y'all know odd
Soxs are OG sponsors our family the most
comfortable socks in the world want to
give much love to odd socks for always
holding us down at the boot Lake C
podcast now it is the holiday season
there ain't nothing like getting you a
pair of Odd Socks for your loved one
getting some underwear getting a hat
whatever you're into they got it odd
Soxs official.com promo code bootleg
save 20% off 20% off at checkout right
now all the licenses WWE uh I mean
Hooters oh some hooters underwear let's
take a peek at these huh bunch of
[__] owls all over here there there
we go M I like it what about Chucky
ain't nothing like some Chucky socks
during the Christmas you know hey
whatever you're into to they got it
oddsocks official.com use the promo code
bootleg right now save 20% off uh and
enjoy the most comfortable socks in the
world also want to give a shout out to
our family over there King pom nice to
think about King
pom what I love about King pom no
tobacco no nicotine we're talking about
straight natural Leaf organic Leaf all
right and and and the cool thing is they
got these tpping infused tips when I
tell you they're tpine infused I mean it
like I love these ones shout out to uh
Sugar Shane sugar Shan [__] I almost
[__] his name up uh sugar Shan Ali
from Phoenix uh he's got his honey
orange here how it works you load that
thing up with your cannabis flour you
got that flavorful tip
inside bam that's what it looks like
when it's all done it's like a work of
art ladies and gent a work of art all
right go to your local smoke shop
wherever you're at they got King palom
go ask for King palom thank me later
okay King pom local smoke shop 7-Eleven
they got them or you can just go to the
website check this out go to the website
king pom.com take care of somebody in
your life that you love and get 50% off
everything you order at King pom.com
using the promo code bootleg 50% off
that's half off half off King pom.com
that's what we're doing right now all
right let's get back to the the
interview um for you like uh you know
can you give me some advice like if you
if someone was listening to this or
they're seeing what you're doing and
they're incarcerated and they're like
[__] this crazy like one it's never too
late to chase your dreams right it's
never too late to get your life on the
right track but also like I can only
imagine that lows of being incarcerated
have to be the extremist of lows at
times they could break you man abolutely
hard to get on the other side out of
that and like think that your life isn't
over you know what I'm saying like what
for you like what would be your advice
if somebody's incarcerated and they just
feel like shit's over like there's no
hope you know what I'm saying like man
just uh block everybody out man that the
uh speak negative you know what I'm
saying try to focus on my [__] just try
to make plans my [__] even if you you
feel like you in a [__] up position
between Rock between the hard play they
denied all your your OT your your last
chance your heav Corpus whatever know
what I'm saying still shoot it in still
trying my [__] cuz you know it's like
winning the lot you got to be in it to
win it you know what I'm saying like a
lot of lifers I knew they didn't even
have nothing in they like man I lost
already [__] it you still got to getting
that law got to wake up every morning
you got to get in that law like be you
got to you got to search my [__] is
loopholes it ain't about you know what
I'm saying [__] be feeling guilty
about what they did and all this [__]
which is cool cuz you know what I'm
saying you got a conscious but at some
time point you don't you know the crime
don't match the time you know what I'm
saying and at some point you gotta
respect it and and it's not about what
we did it's about what the [__] they did
cuz they don't even follow their own
rules and regulations and their laws n
they'll [__] you over if you let them if
you don't if you don't actually keep
search yeah you know when they [__] up
when they when they violate they not
going to say nothing you know what I'm
saying so you got to keep searching for
that loophole cuz was that something you
were doing when you were in incarcerated
where you you were in the law library
just man did it work did you find out
like did you find anything yeah hell
yeah and I grinded it out and I paid for
lawyers and all kind of [__] so you like
found where they [__] up and you I
already knew you know what I'm saying
basically they couldn't do this [__]
that's why they was kind of mad at me
cuz I represented myself at trial fired
my lawyers and [__] but um wait you
fired your lawyers yeah y [__]
they yeah they was trying to milk me uh
[__] Mark gagos ass Char me 100 band
then going to trial to get 75 more
thousand you know what I'm saying I gave
cars yeah all this I kill it and you
ended up represent yourself yeah I
couldn't I was broke from the bail
bondsman to lawyers it it stripped me of
everything you know what I'm saying and
uh sh all I had left was cars and I gave
those up watches but uh other than that
yeah it was it was so when you represent
yourself usually you hear that that's a
bad idea how did how did it go for you
though I mean for sure I'm sure you were
well I'm sure you did research and yeah
oh God I I had all my [__] tight but it
was just they didn't respect it they
didn't like a [__] up in there telling
them know how they laws what the [__]
they laws was eventually I ended up
being right I got back on the pill you
know what I'm saying they deliberately
did some [__] that basically just
violated my rights that shit's crazy I
knew they couldn't do it and they still
did it and but eventually it worked out
and you represented yourself yeah at
trial I lost but I got back on a pill
okay okay you know what I'm saying so I
got to be ner B I can only imagine it
being in the cell the day before you got
to go stand in front of everybody and
represent yourself yeah you probably got
all your notes ready to go no they yeah
they didn't let me do that [__] they
they had me Shackled down to the [__]
chair I was like wasn't it was just
violation for real that's crazy that
they wouldn't even allow you to like
yeah stand up have your hands free to
read notes yeah they yeah he was
violating that shit's crazy said I was a
violent uh you know individual whatever
the [__] but that wasn't the case just
try to discourage me that shit's wild
man damn your life movie is going to be
crazy huh yeah absolutely I got it ready
you got it ready yeah it's already it's
already written just it's open-ending so
what is um your timeline this albums out
I know you guys are working non-stop I'm
sure there's more than a few people that
probably want to do joint joint projects
with you
yeah yeah I got a gang of [__] already
who is there is there any other any
other albums that are in the can any any
joint joint joint projects yeah got a
whole album with [__] man like uh Jay
worthy me and Jay worthy got a whole
album me and RJ got a whole album me and
killer Twan got a whole album me and T
Fly got a whole album I got albums with
[__] you know what I'm saying me and
uh Don Kennedy got a whole album you
know what I'm saying so it's like yeah
and count men [__] K boy got a album
my [__] partner you know what I'm
talking about Jesus yeah so you ain't
playing n is that like do you are you
treating this [__] like a job like
Monday through Friday you got to make
sure you're in the studio like I mean no
I'm treating it like the sale like I'm
in the sale I'm in lock down [__] in
the hole but I'm in the booth it's like
the the best sale in the world I'm like
[__] ain't nothing everything come
to me you know I'm saying that's dope
man what was it like uh for you like
working with someone like Alchemist whoo
is is is one of them ones he's like your
kid you know what I mean like he one of
them guys he a legend Alchemist man he
got a beautiful soul man and he he like
just Aura just you know if you didn't
know him you wouldn't know he he that
you know what I'm saying [__] you know
down the Earth you feel me that [__]
down to earth yeah no it's crazy you
mentioned being in the hole what's that
like uh people don't realize that that
that I feel like they put you in there
to break you oh yeah the shoe yeah
special housing unit that was my second
home
sh I was always [__] up violations
you know what I'm saying so how do you
make the time go
by working out
praying uh you know writing obviously
just writing for sure I wake up all my
sleep with songs Just Right ready to go
y damn I can only imagine I've heard
like my cousin's in in prison and uh I
know the ho
is shitty I can only imagine bro like
eventually I feel like you'd be high off
your thoughts
yeah you be there tripping low key you
know what I'm saying for sure if you
ain't strong you gone yeah that shit's
crazy man uh is there anything cuz I I I
only can assume so many people have been
trying to sign you to a bigger bigger
deal yeah I'm sure the calls have been
coming in about 9 10 offers it's got to
feel good right man I'm yeah but [__]
ain't feel good turning down that much
like you know [__] turned down a half a
million dollars like and I understand it
like so I'm a ticket for for the advance
yeah half a ticket for the Advance on
one of them no couple couple how many
albums was that 50 oh [__] they wanted
uh they
wanted 12 songs that's
it that's a lot they wanted 12 songs so
why why obviously you know why why turn
that down keeping it independent I mean
[__] hit boy done blew that already on
me [__] I was like breaking even you
know what I'm saying I'm going to get
way more than that so you kind of see we
don't own our masters man we just making
a statement man we pushing I think too
you know the thing what's dope about hit
boy is he's like been extremely
transparent about some of the stuff he's
gone through with like predatory record
deals or Pub Pub deals specifically in
the music industry so I feel like if
there's anybody who could kind of be
like hey that sounds good right until it
ain't good way more yeah for sure yeah
we just pushing I mean we just working
man we not really even tripping off the
bread right now we comfortable you know
we know it's going to come later it's
like plant seeds M you know what I'm
saying so we trying to control the
market my [__] control our market and
just create a whole new Lane you know
what I'm saying we going to come through
with the podcast um we're going to do
our own [__] um you guys going to do
a podcast yeah I'm going to have my own
podcast
fire just you interviewing people you
talking about me yeah we I'm going be KK
that's my uh that's my uh my [__] career
criminal entertainment fire so we going
to be [__] with everybody fresh out
the P [__] got out [__] that's still
in the prison you know and just uh
basically trying to change some [__] cuz
man we had we we have a snowball chance
in hell like everything we did we get uh
convicted of cuz we was basically judged
by the bigger brother and the sister you
know what I'm saying so when then you
get out and you got that on your it's
almost like a you know like The Scarlet
Letter like you can't get jobs you know
there certain things you can't get
qualified for if you're a felon like
they really make your life Liv in hell
like for real like you really got to
kind of they almost make it to where you
want to go do some more legal [__] cuz
they make it hard for you to do legal
[__] once you get out get to it got to
get back to it on me yeah for this I'll
be i' have been I'd have been on one
once you apply for that job you got to
hit are you a fell yes or no ain't
nobody applying for no job my [__] no
I'm just saying I'm not I'm talking
about just like most people who get out
they want they want to try to like
straighten their [__] up you know yeah I
mean that' be dope I love the podcast
Direction that'll be hard yeah y yep
would you ever write a book yeah that's
what I'll tell you I'm finished so you
got do the book first then the then the
show or the movie uh no we yeah that's
how it's probably supposed to go you
would think right then be like based on
the number one bestselling novel right
yeah then you got the movie yeah we
doing a documentary you know what I'm
saying we already been chopping it up
with my uncle from New York you know
what I'm saying my dad from New York you
know what I'm saying so it start with
him you know what I'm saying he was a
orphan and [__] and his mama was a doine
my Grandmama hairon addict you know what
I'm saying he was a whole baby you feel
me so she did with whoop and they lived
a rough ass life my [__] and U and you
know he grew up in the orphanage and
[__] he was out there [__] singing in
front of trash cans and all that [__] in
New York [__] like you know what I'm
saying [__] and all that [__] and then
he went to the Marines and did this
thing up up there in Vietnam and got out
you know and spoiled the [__] out of me
you know I was like crazy I heard
Vietnam was Wild Man Buck [__] wild
crazy bro yeah then so your pops was in
Vietnam yeah he was a tunnel rack that
[__] he probably he probably told you
some crazy stories huh man this [__]
was killing [__] theying hoes and they
walk by slit their throat pull them in
pull them in there and sleep with them
oh man ho get full you dig another ho
getting closer to the camp that [__]
crazy hey we got to stop the interview
real quick man shout out to our family
at my bookie NFL season is winding down
you still got some regular season uh
games you can get in on of course the
college bowl games are coming up so much
money to get plus the cash prizes going
down in their weekly Blackjack
tournaments at my
bookie.ag and uh this is what's going on
right uh my book is crazy cuz they're
doing this if you sign up right now at
my bookie use the promo code bootleg all
right claim your deposit match
redeemable up to $11,000 that's right
they're going to match your first
deposit up to
$1,000 using the promo code bootleg
claim your bonus NFL college bowl game
so much going on in terms of what you're
trying to get down with if you want to
gamble if you want to bet all right they
got Blackjack they got roulette they got
it all uh and of course the best odds
anywhere online when it comes to your
sports betting needs so one more time
sign up right now with that promo code
bootleg um and I'm going to tell
everybody this uh you're going to get
your first deposit match up to
$1,000 I'mma put my money I'm feeling
good about the 49ers future BET right
now slam the ners to win the Super Bowl
I think they're taking that whole [__]
bet anytime anywhere with my bookie also
shout out to our good folks over at
blueo make sure you go over to blue.com
right now a lot of people asking me yo
man blueo does that [__] work yeah it
works man find out for yourself though
blue Chu is legit same active ingredient
as viag seis but if you want know if it
works they're going to take care of you
with your first month for free by using
the promo code bootleg at blu.com
that's right blu.com use that promo code
bootleg and get your first month for
free this is how it goes down no awkward
doctors visits none of that if you're
dealing with a rectile dysfunction
you're dealing with too much stress
maybe you're drinking a little too much
you get the whiskey dick I don't know
huh blueo got you all right blu.com
promo code bootleg sign up right now get
your first month supply for free
delivered right to your doorstep for
only $5 in shipping no uh doctor's
appoint it's all online discret
packaging in a blue chewable form come
on fellas it's getting cold outside
let's make sure those [__] stay hard
all right let's get back to the
interview yeah I always heard like uh
Vietnam like in terms of the more modern
like Wars was like the most um
brutal yeah then we're playing over
there yeah he was yeah he slept with his
eyes open [__] that shit's crazy you
imag sleep with your eyes open I be like
that he like this and then Fourth of
July they be tweaking oh cuz he had PTSD
so if you heard like fireworks you
probably Jesus I can only imagine man
that's what they say they say mushrooms
are kill your PTSD man damn so if you
got PTSD you get on that sing man yeah
I'm a little something so I don't like
people standing behind me for sure
that's what I'm saying get on some I
ain't [__] with those shs no we got
to do it we got to document we we got to
do a podcast with you on mushrooms hell
know I should have go
[Laughter]
platinum um yo uh how how do you feel
being because I'm thinking like next
year soon we're going to have the new
freshman cover I feel like it'd be kind
of crazy if you made the freshman cover
how old are you if you don't mind me
asking 52 if you made the freshman cover
at 52 that'd be [__] wild what
freshman cover the double XL you know
have you heard of the double XL freshman
cover not so they XL every year they put
a cover out with like the hot Freshman
Class of rappers like cuz you're kind of
like you're a new artist this is your
first album yeah for sure you know what
I'm saying like that shit's crazy like
how do you feel like cuz you don't like
you know your your kid is kind of like
the OG in the music game for you right
even though you're his OG right but
you're in a very we've never seen this
happen before man but I feel like that's
like a real thing that could happen like
I feel like you could be on the freshman
cover in like three or 4 months man for
real don't don't sleep try to put you
got to pit yourself for that [__] though
like yeah I mean [__] the billboard I
mean anything happen [__] that [__]
crazy man [__] you could be my dad
lowkey bro I'm 36 oh God this [__]
older than you his boy older than
you you was getting it in yeah yeah I
wasting so wait so how old were you when
you had hit 14 oh [__] that's how my
sister was my sister had my niece when
she was 14 yeah was your was was your
was his mom 14 as well yeah oh so that
was like yeah I met but what B was 13 it
was that uh high school that summer
school was that your first time with
with was was hit's mom your first girl
like did you I mean that was my first
baby mama what I'm talking about but you
ain't lose your virginity with her no
man I was like man I was young dog you
was snap how old were you when you lost
your virginity
man young like [__] but like 12 [__]
no like [__] eight or nine [__] like
how old was the girl you [__] when you
were n already like I don't know she
probably was like 20 something oh she
was a child
molester I mean yo she should be in
prison I don't
know it was the reverse R Kelly
happening I mean I just was she a
teacher nah cuz you know these days
teachers is out here [__] hella Kids
N N I I feel I wish I would have caught
that way wish was for real my homie
called me up there he's like come a
[__] and I was like where you at she
she went a crackhead nah n you never I
went up there and and they was really
pulling the train it was so everybody
was just getting it in I looking in the
room he was like come on I like now I'm
cool so you just hopped in yeah when
they left out I went that shit's amazing
oh God oh my
God I raised up out of there jeez I see
I I didn't lose my virginity till I was
15 but I finger [__] a chick when I
was 12 and then I I got my dick sucked
in a Mexican strip club when I was
13 I I uh I went there with my cousin
we're on vacation and he paid to get me
to the strip club is in Rocky Point and
yeah I got domed up by this chick and it
was it was like
$15 super cheap cheap as [__] $15 and
you know I'm saying I don't even won
that one right the strip club still
there wowwow great place where in Mexico
yeah Rocky Point port pinasco the place
called wwas crazy I went in there with
uh with my girl and I was like you know
I got my first [__] [__] I've been
adus though well I've heard of that
place they had like how was it man it
was turned up I've only heard of it I've
never been it was turned up yeah there's
a new place out there me to bring him
back over there's a new place out there
I've heard about it's called Hong Kong I
heard it's good oh know I you know I
wouldn't go obviously I'm married but I
heard it's a good place yeah I went over
there when I first got out [__] oh you
went over there like like this this go
round or the last last time last time oh
okay okay and you didn't you didn't
participate n n hell no I was spoke they
was two was like two to cheap and two
four like what do you want they're
prostitutes you want them to like do you
want them to take you on a date I
wondered if this that easy you know what
I'm saying hold up [__] that's the
whole point of the place respect some
[__] like and back back then cuz what
was that 2012 you got out or 2011 yeah
no uh 20 [__] no damn the [__] did I
get out I don't even know when the [__]
I got out cu was gr my whole life was
that 2014 that was 201 yeah 13 134 yeah
so I got out 2013 oh yeah Adas had it be
cheap as hell back then yeah you're
tripping $20 is for a girl something
like that I was like would you ever have
like girls visit you like like I always
wonder how the visitation [__] Works cuz
you know there's some guys who get the
conjugal visits yeah why a get none of
that none of that cuz you got to be
married right married I got married and
[__] but that then I still I lost lost
my [__] I had like you lost your rights
cuz you got in trouble right y we we
like uh guards like uh I was in the
state this last round and the FAS we
don't get none of that we don't get no
action no n damn yeah yeah I always
wonder cuz you you'll see like the
conjugal visits on TV or like uh these
female guards be out here falling in
love with prisoners and then did you see
that the chick who helped the guy break
out yeah that shit's crazy oh me and now
she's in yeah he tripped yeah like you
[__] that up bro like yeah he [__]
that up yeah that [__] crazy well look
hey the new album is out man I hope
everybody uh for so obviously people can
go buy the album and get one of these
absolutely um big hit no.com my [__]
spell it out b i g h i t n u p
d.com um merch is there merch is there
truth of Z te's the big hit uh free te's
you know I'm talking about the truth is
in my eyes teas the the yams teas all
that and this is one of the crazier the
magazine oh the hood he just said the
hoodie my hoodie my
[__] know I'm talking about and this is
one of the crazy for for this being your
debut album just for people who are not
clear on who's on this album RJ J worthy
baby Stone gorillas Mazy your son hit
booy Snoop Dog Alchemist music Soulchild
Dom Kennedy the homie J Stone try from
the East side is
Benny The Butcher Jesus Miss love that's
impressive man man thank you go bu
tapped in man wait this is new I didn't
see this this is the hood the hoodie
crazy in the hoodie that [__] crazy
truth is in my eyes so make sure you go
support man buy it and
um if you if yeah I mean [__] you can't
stream it so you buy got to buy it on me
you got to buy it I'm out the trunk with
it my [__] like like nip did with the
proud to pay you feel me I'm out the
trunk with it my [__] i a ain't selling
no bricks I'm selling CDs come pull up
support your boy pull big hit I
appreciate you bro thank you H yes sir
respect fire good [__] can we show some
love to our family at harden man shout
out to harden man look if you're in
Vegas you got to pull up you got to say
take me to hardine right now I need to
go to harden they're going to take you
they're going to get you situated Harden
Las Vegas the best cannabis uh
dispensary I've ever walked into in my
life the most craziest selection of
Premium cannabis in the entire world I
mean that place smells like gods uh
sweat it feels it just smells so good in
there it's just oh they got their own
scent they're our family too man so make
sure you follow them online Hardin Vegas
all right shoot them a follow on uh
Instagram also go to Hardin vegas.com
and when you're in Vegas make sure you
pull up to hardine baby